great so this is going to be a map plot
Lib tutorial and this is a very much
intro to matplotlib tutorial so I'm sort
of assuming you have some Python
experience if you want to play along I'm
assuming you have anaconda installed
already which should include matplotlib
1.4 0.3 most likely and all this should
work
so I'm Michael drop boom I'm one of the
lead developers of matplotlib the other
sort of co-lead developer is Thomas
Caswell he's sitting here in the front
so he may interject with help with QA
and and other things this tutorial was
developed by myself and Damon MacDougall
who's down at Texas Austin which is in
turn based on a lot of great work that
Nicola Rozier did he has an online
tutorial with a lot of the same
materials that's really really fantastic
and I definitely recommend checking it
out and yeah so I guess I'll just get
started if you're following along all
I've done here at this point is just
fired up an IEEE Python notebook so at
the command line that should be ipython
space notebook or well Jupiter Jupiter
space notebook should do the same thing
and bring this up this tutorial I'm not
going to assume that you have the this
notebook downloaded necessarily if you
want to kind of type along sometimes
that's more useful but if you are
interested it's here at this github
repository yeah let me make that bigger
there so I'm gonna be a little iffy with
space here because I'm gonna be showing
stuff in the notebook and also in a
external window so it's gonna be cramped
at this low resolution but so if there's
something I'm showing that you can't
read please put your hand up I'll try
and show things okay so as I said this
whole tutorial should work in in Python
one point four point three I have a
couple examples at the end that are new
features in 1.5 just as a taste
so they may not work for you locally if
you're running on anaconda cuz 1.5 isn't
there just yet but will be very very
soon so I'll start with just some
terminology there's some confusing
terminology that's been around in
matplotlib since the very beginning and
very beginning goes back to 2000 so it's
it's really one of the oldest sort of
surviving projects in the scientific
Python community so when we talk about
the figure we're talking about the
entire frame of stuff that's being
worked on okay so that if you're in a
GUI that's the whole window if you're in
a notebook that's the whole output cell
that's everything and axes is a box
within the figure and you can have
multiple axes in one figure and they
actually don't even have to all be
rectilinear we have polar axes we have
all kinds of geographic projections and
all of those are axes but the idea is
one figure multiple axes and then each
axes has an axis right has an x-axis and
a y-axis and so the thing that's a
little confusing is axes is the plural
of axis in English but we often refuse
the word axes in the singular form to
refer to an axis to a box so that's what
gets confusing about it but that's what
we have there weren't very good names
for these things to begin with and
that's so hopefully that'll prevent some
confusion as I talk today so matplotlib
has this concept of backends there's the
whole sort of front-end system that does
the plotting that understands scientific
computing that understands what you want
to render and the back end is how you
get that to the screen essentially right
so we have backends that write out two
file formats like PDF SVG PostScript a
PNG if you just want a a rendered
version and we have backends that hook
into GUI toolkits so python of course
has wrappers for all the major GUI GUI
toolkits so
matplotlib we have g TK q t WX TK i
think that's all the surviving ones
we've had some historical ones OS x
there's one specifically for the mac and
we have sort of within those there's we
support g TK two and three we support QT
four and five so basically if you if you
have a favorite GUI toolkit that works
really well on your system we support it
if your and I won't be getting into this
in this tutorial but if you're embedding
matplotlib inside of a larger
application that happens to be written
in and those GUI frameworks we make that
easy for you no matter what you're using
also and then lastly we have a back-end
that's called the notebook back end or
the NV AG and and that's the one that
works interactively in and ipython
notebook so it works exactly the same as
all the other backends the only
difference is it sends the image over an
HTTP connection to your web browser but
it's still fully interactive it still
supports animation it you can do
absolutely everything you can do in a
regular back-end you can do in the NBA
back-end one limitation about backends
you can't once you've set it in a
particular Python session you can't
change it again and this is sort of for
reasons that we can't control so for
example if you import gtk into your
Python session and then you try to
import QT it explodes because there has
to be one sort of thread you know one
one event loop right so once you've
picked one if you want to pick another
you have to just you know quit Python
start again so I'm going to start by
just demoing the matplotlib notebook
backend so to get that in the notebook
you use this magic which is percent
matplotlib space notebook so that'll
that will tell ipython that's the back
end you want to use and and then by
convention this is usually how we import
matplotlib from matplotlib import
pipe lot as plot I'm gonna just talk
about what pipe lot is in just a second
but for now let's just take that as
convention and then you usually want to
have numpy around to to do anything
useful so you can import numpy as NP and
then I'm gonna I'm just gonna skip a
couple things so I can demo the the
notebook the notebook back in here I'm
gonna run a plot restarted my kernel it
doesn't usually look so cartoonish
that's that's an option that you get but
let's restart the kernel so you can see
the I totally I totally blew my
punchline here at the end of the
tutorial but alright so let's do this
again will do matplotlib notebook
imports okay
so that's normally what you would get
its truncated cuz my I have my window
shrunk let's see if I can fix that part
okay so this is this is what it looks
like the the notebook back end so you
have your plot here normally this fits a
lot better on the screen so apologies
for that but you have a you have a
toolbar here to interact with it and
this is actually the same toolbar that
we have in all our GUI backends this has
been around pretty much since the
beginning in this way the this is the
pan and zoom tool so panning and zooming
works a lot of stuff we do here in the
back behind the scenes to make all that
work but when I'm interacting here it
literally is going back to Python
changing the dimensions redrawing it
sent it back to the browser so it works
really well on a local machine as you
can see it's very smooth if you're you
know if you're someone who runs
notebooks remotely you have to keep in
mind the the network bandwidth that you
may have or the you know that how busy
that the kernel you know it's going to
be so you can pan and zoom it keeps a
history of where you've zoomed to so the
these three buttons here are like in a
browser you have backwards and forwards
and home
they work just like a web browser
there's a tool here where you can zoom
in with a box okay so that's the basic
interactivity and then there's a Save
button here that'll just download a file
of the current state of the plot so
that's the notebook backend as I'm
working through the tutorial I'm not
actually going to use it and the reason
is I want to kind of make changes to the
plots as we go just to be it's easier to
demonstrate it that way and if I were
doing that I would have to constantly
scroll back up and probably make
everyone in the room seasick so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to restart my
kernel since I can't start I can't
change the backend dynamically and this
time I'm gonna use the QT back-end so
now I'm gonna do the same plot but when
I run it it's in its own window and this
window is this window is you know it's a
real sort of local client GUI window
it's running on this machine there's no
network happening here it's just it's a
local local thing like you would expect
but the toolbar is the same the icons
look a little different but the
functionality is all the same you can
pan around and zoom them and use home
and back ok so now now we've got that
most of the preliminaries going and I'll
I'll start talking about how you write
these things so I'll sort of walk
through this first plot really if you
look at this example we sort of have two
lines of import two lines of data which
in this case is just very simple two
lines of plotting and then we're showing
the plot so we import as I said before
the data here is the x coordinates we're
going from negative PI to PI with 256
steps this is all just basic numpy
there's nothing matplotlib specific
going on here the the wide amend then we
have a cosine of X and a sine of X so
we'll plot x verses the cosine
versus the sign have two lines and it
just shows its using the default colors
which are first ones blue the second
ones green there's sort of a lot going
on here that's just happening by default
and that's kind of by design the idea is
simple things should be simple to do
really quick but then once you want to
get into tweaking we provide all that to
so but if you just want to be super
simple you can do it so the first
example and because some of that
tweaking would be to change the colors
in line with yes question ah yeah that's
a very good question and and by the way
I didn't say it upfront but if there are
questions as we go I'm quite happy to
take them as we go I think that works a
lot better than waiting till the end so
yeah the reason the reason there is a
comma here is because plot dot plot is
actually capable of plotting multiple
lines at the same time here we're just
plotting one line here so it always
returns a list and it returns a list of
the lines if you want to get that first
one you can say line comment and it'll
unpack the list and assign it to that
variable but yeah that's a very good
question
plot dot plot and actually maybe I can
even show it here I'm gonna pull up the
help for it can I do it that yeah there
we go
it's an incredibly flexible function in
terms of how the how the arguments it
takes and that all comes from mat the
MATLAB history the sort of MATLAB
inspiration for matplotlib the plot
function sort of does everything these
days I sort of recommend doing that less
and less like trying to keep it to sort
of simple call signatures I think trips
people up a lot less so I won't get into
that but but here for example like I was
saying you can do XY coordinates and say
do this one in green give it another
pair of XY coordinates and do this one
you know in a different style you can do
all that kind of in a one-liner if you
wanted to I don't I don't mention that
in tutorial because I don't think that's
necessary the best
but it's there and it's in the docstring
if you want to learn all about it yeah
right it's one of those things it's been
there for 15 years and and it's it's
hard to get rid of okay
so changing line styles we have this
variable for the first line in a
variable for the second line
we'll set one to blue and one to red you
can update the line width so this is how
you would do it after the fact if you've
created a plot and you want to tweak you
can also do it as you've plotted so we
could have said you know plot X events
against cosine make the color blue
explicitly set the line width everything
always kind of works both ways anything
any of these functions that say set
underscore something are generally also
available as keywords when you plot it
so this line width corresponds to here
in this color so if I run that you see
over here the plot just to sort of
automatically updates
I should mention one thing too if you're
on one point 4.3 some of that automatic
updating doesn't always happen
consistently with one point five we've
really fixed that well Thomas
specifically has really fixed that in a
lot of ways and so there's there's not
as many gotchas there so I'm actually
not even really going to mention those
today
I personally am running one point five
here so that's what you're the behavior
you're seeing okay so beyond things like
style and colors and line widths of
course you can set the limits one of the
things matplotlib has helpfully done for
us here is we've our data goes from
negative pi to positive PI and
matplotlib has rounded up to the nearest
round integers you know when you're at
this scale that's going to be integers
if your data was bigger it might be the
nearest power of 10 or multiple of 10 or
multiple of 100 or whatever often that's
not what you want and again show
heads up on the future in version 2.0
we're not going to do that anymore
it's this sort of helpful rounding to
numbers we've decided maybe not so
helpful but that's what it does for now
so if if you don't like that you
probably want to set your data to
something more more meaningful so here
what we're what we're doing is using the
X Lim functions and why Lim functions so
excellent obviously sets the X limits
and why let'em sets the Y limits and
here we're just going to set it to the
minimum and maximum of the data plus
about 10% of padding that's what the x
1.1 is so if we run that you see
something that kind of reflects I think
the bounds of the data a little bit
better a note now we don't have you know
even numbers right at the edge of the
axes anymore it's really like you know
3.14 is right right around there so it's
very easy to set that like sometimes you
may have data where the data goes up to
here but the interesting part is is you
know just in some corner of it you can
you can easily hard-code that to to just
show parts of it now another thing
that's that's not quite right about this
plot is if you are showing dragon a
trigonometric functions as we are doing
here
you probably want your X scale in terms
of pi naught in terms of integers right
it looks a little funny the way it is so
you can in matplotlib you can both set
where your ticks are and how they're
going to be printed and those are
separate concepts that are somewhat
decoupled so you can really kind of play
with each the X ticks and Y ticks
functions is what you use to tell them
where they are right so here I'm gonna
say X ticks and we're going to put one
it at negative pi PI over 2 0 and then
for Y you know having having 1/2 there
for this kind of data it doesn't make a
lot of sense so we'll just put one at
negative 1 0 and 1 so we run that and
that's what we get so we've changed the
tick locations
okay again this isn't still quite where
we want it because you know 3.14 - it's
not not super friendly given the kind of
the data we're working with so we can
set the tick labels so whereas before we
just gave one argument for the positions
here we're going to give that same
argument again but we're also going to
give it a list of labels and this is
where a really cool feature of
matplotlib comes in it has built-in
support for latex
max expressions so you can you can do
all the basic sort of greek characters
and fractions and square roots and all
that stuff and it all gets rendered
properly so this this content between
dollar signs here is a latex math
expression that's all you really have to
do to get that support this is put
whatever you want that's math in between
those dollar signs so so what this is
going to do is make that actually print
as pi using the PI symbol right and for
here on the y-axis we have an explicit
negative sign here it might be helpful
to have an explicit of positive sign
there just because of what we're working
with so so that's work what we're gonna
use there so we run that and now we have
nice friendly looking X labels that make
sense for this domain right there's a
lot of domains we're just having numbers
as your as your ticks maybe doesn't make
sense you might have categorical data
you might have log scale data and all
that stuff is tweakable we actually have
built-in support for log scaling but you
know if you need to do any of that stuff
it's all there okay so as we work
through this example a little more the
other thing that's not quite
domain-specific for for this kind of a
plot is this is kind of a Cartesian math
plot right and often what you see there
you don't see the the spine these edges
here what we call spines right here we
have four spines on all four sides with
this kind of a plot often you have
the the spines in the middle right
centered on zero so we let you move and
put your spines wherever you want them
you can remove only use some of them
it's this is sort of a very flexible
part of matplotlib so here what we're
doing is we're getting an object for the
current axes GCA stands for get current
axes and so our variable ax ax refers to
the axes here and we can get the spines
and it's a dictionary there's the four
spines are their top right left and
bottom right and we'll take the right
one and we'll set visible to false so
we'll just kind of get rid of it and
same for the top one and then the bottom
spine we don't want at the bottom of the
data anymore we're going to put it at
zero so you can say set position at data
at zero right you can set positions in
terms of the data which is what we're
doing here you can also set positions in
terms of how its rendered to the figure
which is called I think axes yeah no I
think I think so did you can give a
different value here for data which will
which will give it an axis space and in
that case zero is on the left and one is
on the right or zero is on the bottom
and one is on the top and so you can you
can put your spine sort of physically
the way the way it's going to be
displayed in this case it makes sense to
do it relative to the data and put
everything at zero so we do that with
the bottom spine we do that with the
left spine and when you do that you have
something that looks like this okay so
we put the spines in the middle this is
starting to look more like a traditional
math plot might be helpful to have a
legend right so the only other bit of
information you need to give matplotlib
to get a legend is you need to tell what
the labels are going to be in the legend
now you can do this with set label on
the line object or we could have done
that when we made the line object up
front to I'm
trying to walk you through in this
example so the our first line is cosine
in our second line is sign and then the
plot legend function takes a location
for the legend we also have this thing
called best which will automatically
look at the data and find the best place
to put the legend that won't obscure any
of the data so maybe I'll show it both
ways actually here so if we do that we
now have a legend in the upper left the
blue line is cosine if we say best it
probably will arrive at the same
solution in this case ah yeah Thomas
pointed out if you do best and you pan
around every time you pan it'll try and
find a place that doesn't obscure the
data so I can kind of push the legend
out of the way which is kind of fun
that's really the the the best location
of legend is really helpful if you have
some app that's taking random data and
just want to draw something and make
sure that your legend is always in a
reasonable position sometimes it can't
find a best position and it just picks
something but in this case there's
always sort of a good empty space no
matter where you put all this okay oh
yeah when I did home there it I'm gonna
put the limits back which was this this
one here okay so the next thing I'm
gonna talk about is annotations often in
some some plot particularly as you get
down to where you're gonna take it to
management or publish a paper or
whatever you you discover that there are
some interesting points in your data
that you want to highlight and point out
so an annotation in matplotlib parlance
is basically a chunk of text with an
arrow pointing at something it's super
tweakable we have all these different
kinds of arrows there's a there's a
developer we have who just
he's kind of a narrow guy for whatever
reason he's put all kinds of different
arrow styles in and but so what is this
so so in this example we're basically
gonna draw a couple more lines and and
and annotate some interesting features
in the data I think I'm going to run
this one first and then talk it through
because I think it's hard to understand
if you're not seeing what it does so
it's drawn two lines one for the
positive here up to this point and then
we have a little bit of text of course
math text with an arrow pointing at that
data point that's interesting and here's
some more math texts with a nice arrow
and the arrow has a nice curve like I
say this
jae-joon Lee has really put a lot of
effort into that so this looks like a
lot here it's not as bad as it looks so
I'll just kind of walk through the plot
the plot function here is just drawing
one of those vertical lines the annotate
here's the real mean so this first thing
is just this is just a law Tech math
expression if you don't use law tech I'm
not going to I'm not going to walk
through that but suffice it to say that
is the text that gets turned into that
nice-looking math expression XY is the
data point that we want to point at
that's the interesting data point so
here it's T and sine of T and T is here
at 2/3 pi for whatever reason I don't
know why that's the interesting point
it's just for an example and we tell it
that XY refers to data again here you
have the option of doing your
annotations in data space which is the
most common thing and makes the most
sense or you can do it in plotting space
XY text offsets that text a little bit
because you don't want your text right
at the data you want to kind of move it
the way a little bit and often you need
to tweak where the best place to put
that is and text court this is saying
that the that this value is in terms of
points font size is pretty
self-explanatory and then this is the
arrow style I won't get in today but if
you if you look in the docs for arrow
style it's very very flexible um sorry
can you repeat its its relative to the
data point so it's an offset it's it's
it's basically saying the direction that
you want to move the text yes
it's let's in points but it's in it's
not in data space yeah it's it's it's in
the sort of physical space so so sorry
good scrolled here so here by saying
plus 10 plus 30 it's you know 10 pixels
to the right and 30 pixels up and that
just the this is one of those things we
kind of manually tweak to make it look
nice we could have put it over here we
could have put it you know here it's
pretty cluttered we that wouldn't make
sense so that's basically what that's
doing and then we do that again for the
other point down here so and again these
things move with your data right you're
not you're working in data coordinates
okay so the next the next thing about
this example that's a little bit not so
great is the zeros here are getting
obscured right we have a tick line
running or spine running right through
this zero this pie is getting you know
obscured by the data so so one thing you
can do is you can maybe if we make the
fonts a little bigger that will help you
can also render a border around the text
so we can put a white border around the
text which sort of clear out some of
that data and you can even make it semi
parents so I'll have to stretch this out
I think to see it all yes so here here
we're saying we'll put a little a little
bounding box behind the text make it
white with no edge and an alpha value of
0.6 so that's you know sixty forty
percent transparent 60% 65% filled so if
we do that oh why did that not update
maybe if I okay this is one of these
issues where didn't update so anyway now
we have this little sort of
semi-transparent box behind the text
which helps helps to see the text a
little better okay are there any
questions so far
I've sort of gone at a particular speed
that I want to make sure I'm going to
speed for the audience okay then my next
sort of plan here was to make a little
regression into styling so this is a new
feature that went in around 1.4 yeah 1 1
400 was the first time we had styling 1
1 4 Oh has a few styles 1.5 has a lot of
styles so it's kind of a feature that's
that's grown recently we've been working
with the default behavior of Matt plot
Lib here which is not always the right
thing it looks 15 years old which it is
and so we have this new feature that
that lets you very easily write a style
sheet and when I say style sheet that's
with a lowercase s it has nothing to do
with CSS it's a totally a far less
powerful language but it's just enough
so that you can write a plotting style
sheet very easily and then share them
with your coworkers I used to work on a
project called a strop I for example and
they have kind of a corporate style
sheet that they use for all their plots
that uses a lot of orange because that's
their branding right so we make it very
easy to kind of write those things and
share them
if you sew you use this stuff you do
from matplotlib import style and then
style available will tell you which
styles are available this is this is the
1.5 set the 1.4 set is much smaller but
we have the styles that Seabourn has so
if you're just using Seabourn for the
styles and none of its other cool stat
stuff you can you can you don't have to
use Seabourn anymore you can just turn
on one of their styles if you want if
what else do we have we have 538 which
comes from 538 website website and how
they do their plots we have a nice
grayscale style that's helpful if you're
if you're going to print and we also
have this this special one here called
classic which is going to be very
important when we release 2.0 when we
release matplotlib 2.0 we are going to
change the default style it's been very
hard for us to do this so far because
everybody tweets their plots and it's
all based on on you know what the
defaults are what they're going to
change in 2.0 we're gonna have something
that's a lot more modern by default but
if you were relying on the old behavior
it's going to be a one-liner to just go
back to classic mode so that's what
classic mode the class the classic style
is for so it's very easy to use these
things it's truly a one-liner you say
style that use and you give it a name
and it's it can either be one of these
names or it can be a file on your file
system that works or it can even be an
HTTP URL Russian passenger jet the UK
security is doing to protect Americans
abroad next
every day I'll try to talk over it I
guess for now and maybe someone can fix
that so it can be a local file on your
file system or an HTTP URL so like again
like I say with Astro PI they just have
it up on a website and then everybody
can type in that HTTP URL and all their
plots and and get the the
corporate-style
so where's my window there it is okay so
this is the ggplot default style and I
haven't plotted anything in any
differently right that's the key here
all that tweaking we've done so far this
is just one line use the style again it
doesn't know your data and it's not
doing anything data specific it's just
sort of changing the colors and the
styles and the grids and and all that
stuff also for an example here's the 538
style which is here we can
zoom in out a little bit so it's very
easy if you don't like you know a lot of
people have said to us like Matt plot
live I plot with it and it looks like a
scientific paper from the 90s and if you
don't like that we have a we have an
option for you now now what I often do
and just so you know that it works you
can also use style as a context manager
so if you're familiar with context
managers in in Python it works if you do
something like this the style will only
have effect within this block and then
it automatically goes back that can be
helpful if you don't want to do that you
can also just say matplotlib Darcy
defaults which resets all your style
again that only really ever matters if
you're trying to give a demo and okay
well I don't know why that's not working
Oh does it have it the context manager
has a different name okay yeah ok ok any
questions about styles ok all right so
in part 2 I'm gonna go beyond just sort
of tweaking a single axes like we did
and start talking about this whole
concept of a figure is made up of
multiple subplots and multiple axes and
and do some more advanced things with
ticks and stuff so
so there is this subplot command and
this this has sort of an unusual
interface but it turns out to be a
pretty convenient interface again this
this was inspired by how MATLAB does it
and the the first argument here is the
number of rows that you want the second
argument is the number of columns and
the third argument is which once you've
once you've created that grid which
number within that are you going to
going to make so again an example is
probably gonna help illustrate here so
here here we've said we want two rows
one column and then this first one
refers to this first box
they're just numbered left to right top
to bottom right and then to is this
bottom box we can also you know do two
columns one row which is this one or you
know you can whoops you're gonna have as
many as you want you can do eight by
eight it stays you know it tends to slow
down when you do that but it works so if
if your axes happen to fall on a grid
like that and you really want a grid
arrangement it's super convenient to do
it but of course you don't have to work
on a grid you know it's fairly common
you might have two up top and one at the
bottom and so if you want more control
you can actually get right down to where
you want each one to go in terms of top
bottom left right so that's what what
the axes command lets you do these
values here are all scaled zero to one
on the whole figure so so here what
we're saying is this is actually its
left bottom with height is the order so
this is saying the the left bottom is
going to be 10% into the figure and the
whole whole width and height will be 80%
which leaves another 10% on the other
side right
so this will make two things and they
will actually overlap okay so there's no
restriction saying that they can't
overlap this is and they get drawn in
the order that you create them so in
this case we've made one in the back
first and then this one in the front and
you can so you can you know use this to
house say a zoomed in section of your
data pretty easily this example here
just going to again do some more kind of
funky things right you can you can do
that if it makes sense basically we we
give you enough bullets to shoot
yourself in whatever foot you would like
okay so earlier I had talked about the
ticks right and how easy it is to change
to sort of manually change where they
are and how they're formatted we also
let you override how they are
automatically chosen and how they are
automatically formatted so you can write
classes that one is called a locator
locators automatically decide where the
tics should be for matters automatically
decide how the the values of those tics
should be printed we include a bunch of
options there sort of built-in if none
of those are good enough for you it's
it's we have a proper API for overriding
that behavior so just to go over some of
the built-in locators we have one called
the null locator that'll just give you
no tics the index locator will let you
actually specify the the multiple that
you want here we're doing you know an
offset of 1 and then multiples of 3
there after you know we don't
necessarily know what's best for your
data but you do so we let you you know
choose those things we could have used
this one for example in our in our trig
example right and used multiples of Pi
right
the fixed locator is is actually what
comes into play when you explicitly set
what they are this is just arbitrary I
want these ticks right the auto locator
which is the the sort of default that
you get when whenever you plot all all
it really tries to do is make sure that
there's never too many ticks right
because obviously if you have too many
ticks all the text runs together or it
gets obscured you don't want that so the
auto locator is just kind of clever
about like let's put enough there that
they don't run together and there's of
course a log locator if your data is log
scaled that knows how to do decades this
is log locator of two obviously but you
can have whatever base you want
okay so now we can't are there any
questions on locators okay I don't
really have a slide for this but it's
it's it's pretty easy to write your own
so don't feel like if none of these fit
your data that it's an impossible task
to to write your own it's in the
documentation so now I'm going to take a
little digression here and talk about I
think sort of history of our different
api's and interfaces so I didn't start
matplotlib John Hunter did in in 2000
and he was a neuroscientist and used a
lot of MATLAB and saw a lot of other
people using MATLAB it was very familiar
and he wanted to create his tool sort of
to be familiar so that it would be an
easy sell to people who are already
using MATLAB also because MATLAB was
doing a lot of things right not
everything but so this sort of
traditional interface for matplotlib has
been based on MATLAB and that's what we
call pie plot it used to be called pylab
pie plot it's just a new name because it
doesn't include all of the numerical
stuff that MATLAB did and it is it's
very convenient as you've seen every all
my examples so far have been in PI plot
and I haven't had to explain too much it
just kind of for the most part is very
convenient works really well the problem
is it doesn't scale it's it's and the
main reason for that is that it's
stateful right you always have a concept
of what is the current figure that I'm
plotting to and what is the current axis
that I'm plotting to so you just make an
axis and then you start plotting to it
and it just keeps adding to that axis
and then you add a new axis and now
you're plotting to that other one and
that's that's great sort of in an
interactive session where you're
exploring where it isn't so great is if
you you want to move code around and
write a library and have it explicitly
go to one axis because now you have to
keep track of well what's my current
axis and oh I moved that around and
things are breaking and moving
different thing so there's another API
in matplotlib that we really encourage
people to use when they want to kind of
take it to the next level and and be
starting to write libraries with
matplotlib or things that are more
reusable and so we call that our object
oriented API yes yes they are online
yeah sure no problem it's right here at
the top so it's on github it's under D
MacDougal which is daemon McDougall and
it's the strata MPL tutorial I know
we're not at strata but I'm I am raising
slides okay so the object-oriented API
so the the api's are not significantly
different but the main difference of
course is you have to be explicit about
which access you're working with and
which figure you're working with be in
the object-oriented API so here for
example is how you the pipe lot API you
say make a figure and then we use make
this subplot it knows that you want to
make it in this figure because it's the
current figure okay in the
object-oriented API you make a figure
but then you operate on that figure
right see I'm saying figure dot dot or a
figure dot adds subplot right so I'm
explicitly saying this is the figure I
want you to put the subplot on so that's
the fundamental difference but it really
buys you a lot because you're being
explicit and it makes putting these
things into functions and and moving
them around a lot easier are there any
questions on that
all right so now I'm gonna get to some
cool stuff and just some things that I
think are pretty pretty cool in
matplotlib that I think it does pretty
well so yeah I don't think so
not nothing yeah it's I mean it yeah
it's it is making a few less function
calls because it doesn't have to go get
the current figure but I doubt that
that's a significant amount of time yeah
all right so so let's start we'll make a
new figure none of this is none of this
is new from what we've done so far but
we're going to make a new figure I'll
pop up that window and put it in front
sorry I need a show here
if there's any Mac developers in the
audience who know how to make Windows
pop up in front we would love to talk to
you this is I don't you've seen me do
this the whole time here every time we
pop up a window in the Mac it for some
reason puts it in the background we've
had that this problem for years and
never found the solution it doesn't
happen on Linux or Windows ok so so here
we're gonna this example is basically
going to show how you can have data that
is constantly updating that you're then
going to display so you might have live
data you might have say you know an
audio stream coming in you might have
real-time financial data and you want to
every time that data is updated update
your plot you can also you know it
doesn't have to be real-time you can
also save animations out as video files
we have full support for using ffmpeg to
make a video out of something and it's
all the same API so this this first
chunk of code here this is basically
setting up data so the the animation
we're going to be making is a bunch of
rings that are expanding so I'm not
using real time data here obviously
because I knew our network would
probably not work very well so it's all
this sort of computed canned data here
but basically we're just making a bunch
of random random circles okay and here's
the here's the plotting part we use the
scatter command we give it x and
y-coordinates an array of sizes and just
setting some edge colors and face colors
on it and then we're setting our limits
to 0 to 1 and we don't need any ticks
for this example so let's do all that
and see what that looks like
I'm sure why that didn't update but but
it trust me it'll work after the next
slide I think okay so with an animation
obviously what you want to do is you
have your data you give matplotlib your
data but then you want a callback that
gets called each time so that you can
update that data so that that update
function in in the real world is
probably a network request right when
you when you get updated you go fetch
some more data from somewhere or you you
fetch some more data from disk or
whatever it's going to be here we're
just recomputing some values we're gonna
we're gonna make things expand I don't
need to go too much into detail but just
suffice it to say all I'm really doing
here is changing the data in our numpy
arrays in place and then and then
returning it again and then all we need
to do is is tell matplotlib we use this
func animation thing this is where all
the animation stuff gets tied together
so far we've just done regular plotting
we've written an update function func
animation you give it a figure you give
it our update function so this is this
is what will we get called on each frame
and then the interval I think is in is
in milliseconds yeah blitt equals true
is is going to mean
I don't care about you drawing the ticks
every time you can you can basically
tell them that plot loop to cache all
the axes and all the stock stuff I'm
just going to be updating my data I
don't need you to deal with the text
every time and you can give it the
number of frames when you're doing
actually the the number of frames I
think is ignored if you're just doing
things live if you were gonna save this
as a video to disk it would save that
many frames out and when you put all
that together why is it not updating hmm
huh okay I'm having demo luck here yeah
yeah I may restart the colonel hairnet
okay do I have yeah don't have imports I
think I should yeah I'll need to do the
cutie magic to get a window actually you
know what let's try it this way I think
we may have more luck let's try it in
the notebook so I'll go back to all
these animation ones and just run them
again or we need it one more here this
one so that's where it's gonna be I'll
have to scroll back up to it do our
update function animation there we go
that's what's supposed to look like okay
so the three pieces we've put together
together here to make this animations we
did a scatter plot with these random
circles we wrote an update function and
all that update function is just kind of
expand them out and when they get to a
certain size they pop and then put that
together with func animation thing so
there's not a lot you have to do beyond
sort of basic things one would expect
yeah yes in terms of file formats and
stuff yes so it uses ffmpeg under the
hood to do that so anything any file
format it supports which is most of them
yes and yeah also image magic so you can
save an animated gif that way right yeah
that's right you can also just if you
just want the raw frames and not encode
it into a video you can get that too all
right so that's animation
trying to decide if I'm gonna stay in
notebook mode or okay that might as well
stay stay in the notebook mode at this
point so now I've come to a section that
will only work in 1.5 so if you're on
anaconda it's not quite in there yet but
we 1.5 should be an end a condom very
soon as far as I know we're just having
a couple last-minute glitches so 1.5
adds this really cool new feature for
handling labeled data
traditionally what we've sort of forced
you to do is get your data into numpy
arrays before you give it to us
so that means if if you're working from
a database if you're working from pandas
if you're working from you know any sort
of data frame type thing we didn't have
direct support for that so you would
have to extract your data get it in a
numpy array and then give it to us if
you want it to work or you know pandas
has all kinds of built-in support for
doing that but now we're trying to do
that ourselves so it'll work with more
than just pandas and we'll work a little
a little more smoothly so for this
example I'm have this automobile data
it's just a fun little data set that has
the miles per gallon the number of
cylinders horsepower weight acceleration
of a bunch of cars and I think it's like
they're mostly pretty old cars from the
seventies and eighties for whatever
reason so I've just loaded this it's CSV
data and I've used the Panda to load
pandas to load it because it makes it
easy once you have a data frame like
this all you have to do is pass your
data frame in as a data keyword argument
to any function in matplotlib it's
pretty much any function maybe there's
some exceptions to that but all the
basic scatter plot plot all that stuff
works so you pass the data frame in as
this data argument and then rather than
having to pass a numpy or race for each
of the dimensions you can just pass in a
dream and this is the name of the column
in the data frame right so the these
names here directly matched to the the
column names in the data frame so in the
case of scatter plot here the order of
arguments here is X Y color and size
no sorry size and color hmm yes it'll
also work on keyword arguments so if I
had explicit you means so if I
explicitly said colors is this yeah so
the old the old way would have been you
know to get to extract each of these
columns out first now it's just a simple
a matter of doing that and you can do
whatever you want and when you do that
you got a plot that looks kind of like
this sort of all in one line of code
that used to be many many lines of code
oh yeah sure and and this is using the
old jet color map which is not terrible
for this kind of categorical data
because I'm talking about this is they
think this is number of cylinders here
right but let's use our new friendly
color map
I know with this data maybe the other is
a little better but so anyway we have
miles per gallon versus wake here
heavier cars to pick you know I mean
it's what you would expect heavier cars
get a little worse miles per gallon and
the size is indicating horsepower right
these heavy gas-guzzling cars have more
horsepower right yeah so so that's
something we're really excited about I
think it's kind of at the point where
like 80% of it's done it's really cool
there's some you know edges that we want
to work on over time to make this even
better ok any questions about labeled
data yes
the date format from pandas well we have
a pan is person here in front oh oh yeah
so yeah so I think the answer to your
question is if you have a date/time
column from coming from pandas those are
generally the numpy date/time 64's now
we don't we don't have direct support
for that in that plot live yet but it's
on our to-do list and so eventually that
should work but yeah but it doesn't
currently so yeah I'm actually doing
pretty well on time but I have a kind of
a couple more examples and then I also
have a have sort of just a Show and Tell
section here to where I'm not going to
get into any deal to details but I think
it's helpful to know what can be done
so there's scatter plot I used a little
bit of scatter plot in the example
already we do have a bar plotting we
have built-in support for histograms
that end up as bar plot like things we
do contour plotting so if you have image
data like this and you want to sort of
plot through your contoured regions that
works really well it's it and it's
incredibly flexible in terms of how you
can tweak it and control it we have
support for images and mapping them to
any color map you can also control the
the normalization the sort of mapping
from values to colors can go through any
sort of function so if you want a log
scale that you can if you want to you
and you sort of scale to the color
mapping it's very easy to do we do
quiver plots and also we do Quivers and
also Barb's which is somewhat related
that meteorologists like to use that's
angle and and in magnitude as well sort
of combined yes
it's not in the notebook I didn't put it
in the notebook because at this point
I'm just kind of trying to save a little
time all of these however if you go I'll
scroll back up to the top none of this
is a secret so all of these are from
Nicola Rouge's tutorial it has sort of a
long-- URL here but if you if you search
Russia a matplotlib tutorial it's the
first hit on Google all of these
examples are from that and actually on
his website if you click on it you do
get to to the code
so yeah we have quiver plots we have pie
charts if you really really have to have
them there they're the the greeting
stuff just I didn't really use a lot of
grids in the examples but it's it's
pretty flexible you can control major
and minor lines and and exactly how they
look we do have polar plots and not only
can you do lines on them you can do
shapes on them as as in this example we
have 3d support and I think I have a
more I have a 3d example below so our 3d
support is pretty good for a lot of
things but we don't use OpenGL we don't
use a real 3d library to do it it's all
sort of 3d done as if it's 2d so some of
the limitations there are if you have it
doesn't have a proper Z buffer so some
things can can either be slower than
they need to be or you can have
background stuff obscure foreground
stuff in certain certain difficult cases
so that's kind of the kind of the
limitations of matplotlib 3d stuff but a
lot of people use it for a lot of things
so it is usable for real work and the
nice thing about it the thing it does
that I that no other tool I've ever
found does is it makes really nice print
because at the end of the day you get 2
D vectors out that scale perfectly most
other tools use opengl and render in the
GPU or something and from that they get
a bitmap but then that's something that
doesn't work very well in print so
that's really I think mat mat plot libs
secret advantage to the 3d stuff is that
it works really well in print
okay yeah so I do have a 3d example here
just to show how easy that stuff is to
do it's all through the same kind of
simple interface it's just now rather
than x and y we have XY and Z right so
this example even though it's a lot more
lines of code than what we've seen so
far is following the same pattern more
or less we're making some data this is
like a mobius space example and we make
a figure we make a subplot we tell it
this is the key the key piece for 3d you
just tell it what the projection is
going to be and you say I want it to be
I want this to be a 3d axes we also have
geographical axes if you want we have
like a mala weed projection and all
these things that that people who do geo
stuff or Astro stuff tend to like but 3d
is a special case of that too and you
pass it in the XY and z coordinates and
the triangles and a color map and you
show the plot and here's our little
mobius strip and all of this is you know
movable the frame rates are not as great
as if we were using something like
OpenGL but they're not bad you know it's
it's usable did you have a something to
add on 1.5 stock yeah
does 1.4 do something different oh so so
yeah but that's the 3d stuff and it all
works in the same way you don't have to
leave the tool or use a different tool
and you can put 3d axes and 2d axes on
the same figure if you want alright and
then this last example I think what I'll
do here because I have a little extra
time I'll show this one last example and
then maybe I can take requests from the
audience to show other features or talk
about other features that you may be
interested in so I kind of I kind of
spoiled spoiled the headline on this at
the beginning of the talk but we have a
feature that makes plots look like xkcd
plots and it adds this sort of wiggle
tava lines it changes the font and the
nice thing is it works with absolutely
everything it works with 3d plots it's
it it it really it really is a total
general solution to the problem and
people so people people you know they
see this they laugh it's funny you know
but in in certain domains so I used to
work for an architectural CAD firm and
in that domain they're really big on
this actually and all the CAD tools if
you ever see them have a feature like
this to draw a blueprint as if it were a
sketch and the reason they do that is
because if you if you give someone a
blueprint
it looks really final and they're not
they're not as willing to say like no I
think the bathroom should be over there
but if you give someone a sketch that
looks hand-drawn and looks kind of rough
they're much more likely to kind of
tweak it and play with it and so it
works really well in that domain I think
in data science if you really are trying
to communicate something that's kind of
rough and you're showing a fitted curve
that has nothing to do with real data
but you think this is kind of how it
behaves
using this can be helpful because
because you are communicating this is
just a rough idea of what I think the
data does not this is what it
you know so you know it's it's it's fun
and all but I I think it has some
legitimate uses as well
and we have some more examples of this
in our Docs with some some other plots
from xkcd that we've recreated this way
and randall munroe the author of xkcd
knows about this he actually sent me a
signed copy of his book when I told him
about it so that was pretty cool
so okay so this this is my summary stuff
I'll do that and then and then we have a
good 20 minutes approximately and I can
I can take questions from the audience
or demin demonstrate features that that
I didn't cover if anyone's interested so
in terms of of where to learn more the
best advice I can give you is we have a
gallery and I'll pull that up
oh the network I don't sorry
mine the Wi-Fi is down but so it often
happens is you have an idea you know you
what you know what you want to plot but
you don't know what it's called or you
don't know how to do it the best way to
solve that problem is we have a gallery
that's just lots and lots of pictures
and you kind of find the one that looks
closest to what you want to do click on
it and the codes right there and you can
learn how to do it so that I think is
often the most efficient way to figure
out what you want to do so all our
examples are are online you can wit with
the code and just copy and paste and
start from there that's that's my best
advice you know we also have a bunch of
external learning resources this
tutorials online it's based on a longer
tutorial that's even more in-depth
niccola's ruiji a developed that's
that's really fantastic so I recommend
going through it there's also a bunch of
books listed on our website that have
been published recently they're good on
very specific topics there's one
specifically about interactivity with
matplotlib there's one there's a
matplotlib cookbook that's really just
sort of a nice way to start
Stack Overflow is another good resource
there's Tom Thomas on Stack Overflow
quite a bit so he's answered a lot of
good questions there and and then of
course we have a users mailing list
that's very friendly and since we moved
to github a lot less traffic because now
the issue things that are questions
versus issues have been sort of sorted
out so it used to be our users was so
high traffic that people were afraid of
it it's not so bad anymore so it's a
good it's actually a good place to ask
questions that are if the type I need
how do I do X in matplotlib and then the
questions of the type I think X is
broken in my plot Lib are are sort of
best on the github issue tracker so
those two sort of been separated out and
it's all it's all sort of a it's under
the Python license which you can think
of as bsd-style it's close enough it's
compatible and if you're using it in
scientific research we do ask that you
cite us it's not a requirement a lot of
pay a lot of the journal publishers
actually don't like that requirement so
we're happy to waive it in that case but
that's kind of the one thing we ask is
just to get our name out that we're
being used is to be cited yeah so that's
that's the end of my content and now I
guess I'll just open it up I can I can
show other examples if there's things
people are particularly interested in or
if there's any questions about what I
covered yes
yeah
sure so we support all the major raster
formats we support PostScript PDF SVG
and we all all of that is you know code
we've written ourselves because we found
that the tools for doing that generally
we're not good with large datasets and
and don't scale very well so we have
really good support for all those it's
writing it out it's just as simple as
figured savefig and you give it a file
format and by default it looks at the
extension if you don't want to do that
you can also override what the format is
that's so anything that you that you
bring up in a window tweak around change
the limits and stuff you can ultimately
do that that's right that's right
all all of the file for all of the
output file formats are supported by all
of the backends yeah that's true now it
hasn't always been true but it's yeah
and one other little twist on that that
we have is if you happen to be
publishing in LA tech I don't know if
anyone is we have a mode where all the
text rendering in the plot also happens
through la Tech and so it will look
exactly like your document and you can
even pull it in I used to work in
astronomy so we the double-a s had their
own la tech style you can pull that in
and then all your plots will pick that
up and and everything looks right within
your paper so because we come from
science that stuff is important
historically
oh yeah so another thing you can do
there's often a trade-off when you when
you write to a vector format of do I
want that in a pure vector or is this
like gonna have so many small little
objects the file size is enormous right
so in certain cases if you have a
million points on it and we've actually
had the problem where where Adobe Reader
will crash right because it has just the
files just too large in that case you
can have it selectively rasterized parts
of the plot so maybe all the text is
still a vector but the data becomes an
image right so it's very easy
that's artists dot set rasterize true I
think so on any of those things like a
line plot or a scatter plot you can say
set rasterize equals true and then when
it writes it out it will be converted to
an image first so that's kind of handy
there was a question over here
yes so there's a whole interactive
callback system that if you're working
at the low level of mouse clicks and
keyboard events works pretty well the
sort of thing of selecting data and and
being able to automatically get a subset
of data
I'd say that's something we're working
on and hope to improve yeah yeah maybe I
can even bring that up let me make sure
I have the right back-end selected here
but we so there's a whole bunch of demo
there's a whole folder of examples about
interactivity which is a good place to
start
okay good I have the right back-end so
if I do
sorry about the text size I'm not doing
anything other than firing up an example
here event its event handling right
it's that where lassu is yeah here's the
lasso demo so
that doesn't seem right now part live
dog widgets oh hold on
here's writing I have through if I do
this I think it'll work
checkout 1.5 mmm okay maybe that example
is currently broken no okay
oh sorry I'm in the wrong environment
okay Pam
here we go
okay sorry I just had a version mismatch
that's all that was going on there so
here's a scatterplot and you can draw
around your points and it finds them on
you'd get a callback on that and then
you could highlight some other plot it's
all there I'd say it's the kind of thing
where like it's all possible some of the
the ways in which it's made easier in
other toolkits we'd like to kind of
emulate and and shamelessly steal but
yes
mm-hmm
yeah so I guess your question is sort of
like there's there's this question of
interoperability between map lot live
and other tools
yes
right so there's this I think certainly
among the the the projects I've talked
to you know Boca which is now you know
at my current employer and and and and
plotly to a certain extent and and MPL
d3 is a tool that converts matplotlib to
d3 which you can run on a website all of
these various projects realize that
there's a strong need for better
interoperability and we're all aware of
it and we're we're I think it's kind of
the the big thing right now to get to
get an answer for that so that you could
develop a plot and matplotlib and then
turn it into a boca plot when you
publish on the web but use matplotlib
when you publish in a paper right but
have it all come from the same source
like that that really is the kind of
world we'd want to get to we're not
there we're not there now things like
MPL d3 sort of really pointed out that
you can make a plot in matplotlib but we
didn't make it easy because it wasn't
conceived from from the front we didn't
make it easy to go in there and figure
out what's in there and convert it to
something else but but we want to get
there part of the part of the work we're
doing now is I don't know if you're
familiar with trail it's that the
ipython project uses and came out of
there we're we are converting matplotlib
to use a lot of that internally and what
that allow us to do is to serialize our
objects much easier and from there
hopefully convert that to something that
we all agree on as an interchange format
and and and start to do these kind of
things you know I think for basic
plotting we're gonna be able to solve
that problem where it gets tricky is
matplotlib has some special feature here
that boca doesn't have what do we do in
that case you know those are sort of the
big open hard to solve questions
yes
yes so we generally have been pretty
careful about backward compatibility at
least at least trying to be so when we
when we break backward compatibility
it's usually about accident and let us
know yeah or will give you yeah or will
do sort of a deprecation cycle where for
one release something will be deprecated
you'll get warnings and then the next
release it'll stop working that's
generally what we've done with 2.0
that's coming out in a few months that's
the first release where we've pretty
much said we we can't be super careful
about backward compatibility on this one
because we really want to update the
styles and bring them into the modern
world however in the case of 2.0 we
really are hoping that if you care about
things behaving the way they used to
behave matplotlib style use classic
should solve most of those problems
because because that will sort of set
the styles all the way back to how they
used to be yes
oh I have a long list the coast question
in case people couldn't hear is was you
know what what about the library do I
not like is that the question basically
well this this sort of serialization
issue is clearly one where you know for
example one of the things we do when you
plot a histogram we take your data we do
it we bend it into histograms and then
we create a bar plot and we return you
that bar plot but now we've completely
lost the connection to the original data
and how it was converted to get to that
bar plot so tools like MPL d3 if you do
histogram it can't actually ever get
back to your original data and and then
you know maybe you want to change the
bending maybe you want to tweak
parameters on the histogram we can't do
it because the original data has been
been lost and so one of the things we'd
like to do is in those cases of
histogram or those or there's a bunch of
examples but it's sort of these
higher-level plotting things we want to
start having classes that will retain
all of the information of what came in
so that we can redo that more easily
what else would be a sort of top there's
a lot of inconsistencies in in terms of
how like colors behave and how alpha
blending behaves that have just kind of
organically grown that we'd like to
clean up and make behave consistently I
know Thomas has a long list two-fifths
speak up I mean yeah yeah yeah it's it's
you know it's one of the oldest projects
that's still being actively maintained
in this community and so we have a lot
of historical baggage and you know when
matplotlib was started there was no
numpy unit testing was was not really a
thing that everybody did yet you know it
was Python 1.5.2
you know a lot of a lot of things have
changed since then and it's harder to
sort of pick up those things because
when you're when you have all this
historical baggage than it is when you
starting fresh and so we're we're you
know we're constantly swimming upstream
on that and we try to you know yes yeah
yeah so yeah yeah the concept of artists
so everything can I get this back up
every sort of visual thing that you see
is an artist it's a it's a base class
but essentially for everything so an
axis is an artist each of these little
pieces of text is an artist the scatter
points are an artist and so if if you
want to write a new kind of thing that
gets drawn so say well one that we have
that was done fairly recently is like
the Goro shading we get you can you can
do a triangulated mesh of Goro shading
that's that's just a new artist and you
add a new artist type and then you get
support for that but but a lot of the
stuff that's common to all of them is
implemented in the base class does that
sort of answer your question or
mm-hmm
yet we're a pretty open team and we have
sort of just people show up and commit
and and contribute stuff all the time
and and it's it's always really nice to
see so if you were looking for that
reason to help out you know by all means
we're happy to have it and and we've
always had a very sort of it's very easy
to get commit rights and we've never
regretted it it's it's you even less so
now with git I think it's a lot it's a
lot it's a lot less critical who has
commit rights because things are getting
reviewed and people are seeing what's
going on but even when we were on SVN in
the old days you know people people tend
to take their commit rights seriously
and and be careful and and so so we've
never really been very closed in that
sense okay well I think we just have
sort of the five minutes to move to our
next class now so are there any other
quick questions or okay then I think
we'll call that it and thank you thank
you very much
you